[Music]
[Applause]
but let's bring in Mike Florio of pro
football talk live the co-host and
contributor to football night in America
also Mike has a new book on our way home
currently available online wherever
books are sold and all the proceeds go
to Mike's local animal shelter how would
you sum up this book Mike a a for the
holiday type book
it is a holiday book that lands at the
intersection of its a Wonderful Life and
A Christmas Carol and people have said
to me your book is kind of dark and I
said have you ever watched It's a
Wonderful Life George Bailey is ready to
jump off a bridge and end his own life
for crying out loud A Christmas Carol is
a story about a miserable old bastard
who is visited by ghosts who ultimately
show him dead in a cemetery you got to
go through some Darkness to find some
light so the story is dark but it's also
light-hearted and it has I think a
positive message about renewing brok
broken relationships with family members
or others that you would like to have a
better relationship with in the holiday
season is a perfect time to use that as
a spark to try to rekindle those old
relationships it sounds like you though
are you describing you a little bit dark
but I don't know anything about that no
no I no no no I don't know dark I don't
know it depends depends on the day it
depends on my mood why are you wearing a
Vikings uh hoodie today closest and the
cleanest that's the Wardrobe approach
for the Morning Show on PFT live because
usually I cut it as close as I can to 7
o'clock because all I have to do you
know the shorter your commute the more
likely you are to be late so all I have
to do is go up a flight of steps to my
studio so in that o crap moment of what
am I going to wear oh that's close
that's clean I'll put that on I'll go
upstairs so I'm fresh from our show that
obviously leads into your show on
peacock could you see the Chargers
firing Brandon Staley during the season
I think think a normal team would I
think a normal team would have fired him
after he blew that huge lead against the
Jaguars in the playoffs
now I've been calling for much of the
season the Chargers the best
dysfunctional team in the NFL because
they're clearly dysfunctional but of all
the dysfunctional teams they've got a
franchise quarterback and they've
managed to win a few games but it really
is inexcusable when you think about all
the injuries to the quarterbacks in the
AFC this year that the jck that the
Chargers didn't make a run that they
weren't in contention with all the these
guys dropping like flies and the
Chargers with Justin Herbert can't
figure out how to consistently win so I
think a normal team would fire Brandon
Staley today whether or not Chargers
owner Dean Spanos is going to pull the
plug on the final three games of the
Season give Kell Moore a little bit of a
try out something to think about as he
looks for a new head coach although I
think they need to after last night Dan
I think they need to hit the reset
button there's a cultural issue there
you had guys quitting on the team and
you're going to have guys in that locker
room given the side eye to the ones who
quit the guys who tried versus the ones
who didn't and the new coach first order
of business is going to be fix that
because you're going to have guys still
under contract next year some of whom
tried and some of whom didn't and now
you've got to deal with that on top of
everything else going forward it feels
like we look at the Chargers and we go
boy those are great uniforms like we
don't we don't there nobody looks better
at losing than the Chargers do because
of their uniforms it's it's like a weird
phenomenon I don't know if there's any
other team in any other sport where you
go they're not very good or they always
lose big games like the the criticism is
nowhere near probably where it should be
for the Chargers why is that I don't
know but you're right they just kind of
float around and nobody ever really
expects anything from them just to look
good in their uniforms as long as you
look good in your uniforms it's okay if
you're at 500 it's okay if you don't
make it to the playoffs it's okay if
you're one and out there isn't that
passion
loud fan basee that other teams have
that are demanding change and maybe
they're just gas lit by the fact that
ownership isn't going to come in and
make big changes I mean really you think
about last year they could have fired
Brandon Staley and hired Shawn pton and
kept him away from Denver and how much
better would the Chargers be this year
look at what Payton's done with Russell
Wilson all that remember all that stuff
he said to Jared Bell of USA Today and
he got dragged for it it I don't think
he meant to be on the record but hey he
was on the record he said it and here we
are in mid December and he was right
about everything he said about the
Broncos about Nathaniel Hackett about
the Jets he was right about all of it
and look at where the Broncos are one
game behind the Chiefs for the division
lead and they could still win the AFC
West it's amazing and the Chargers could
have had him because I think between the
two jobs I don't know this but all
things equal I think pton takes the
Chargers job because of Justin Herbert
it's an attractive
job how many jobs will be open well let
me go back to the report by Tom Curran
because it was it was kind of a strange
report by Tom
Curran because he didn't even do it on
his own social media uh Boston Globe
didn't pick it up ESPN didn't pick it up
like it it was reported that a decision
had been made on Bill bich when they got
back from Germany when they lost there
it just didn't catch on so I'm curious
why it didn't and do you think that the
Patriots have already told Bill what
their decision is well let me tell you
where I did catch on it caught on at pro
football talk.com because it was by far
our most visited story of the week it
contributed on Wednesday it was our
biggest traffic day since the day Aaron
Rogers tours Achilles tendon so it
caught fire but what you're speaking to
Dan is this wasn't something Tom Curran
wrote for nbcsports boston.com he was on
some other show and he just said it and
I talked to Tom about it before I wrote
anything because I wanted to make sure I
was getting it accurately because I saw
someone aggregated and then reaggregated
it's like let me just make sure I get
this right and Tom said you know
sometimes you write something and you
say something and maybe what you said
you wouldn't have written but what you
said is true and it's true so I think
the truth is this decision made
preliminarily not implemented yet could
have been implemented at any point
between then and now maybe after the
Giants game it could have been
implemented I think right now riding the
victory that they had last Thursday
night in Pittsburgh if they would beat
the Chiefs on Sunday if they build some
momentum down the stretch maybe that
decision changes nothing's final until
it's final and I also think Dan the
other wrinkle here is Robert Craft would
like to land the plane in a way that
lets him have his cake and eat it too
move on from Bill bich but get get a
draft pick or two from the next team
that hires him if I'm belich why am I
going along with that why am I agreeing
to an outcome that causes my next team
to give up draft Capital to get me I dig
in my heels and I say look you either
bring me back next year and pay me 20
million plus or you fire me I'm not
going along with this deal and if
there's any deal to be made it would be
this he walks away free and clear the
Patriots owe him nothing for next year
if he doesn't coach and he can go to a
new team unencumbered by any expectation
that the Patriots get something in
return that needs to go they need to set
that aside and just let bich go wherever
he wants to go he's Mike Florio he gave
us pro football talk he has co-host with
Chris Sims also a football night in
America contributor in his new book on
our way home we had Nick right on he
works for Fox Sports One he's a Chiefs
apologist and he was saying that you had
cadarius Tony lining up off sides
numerous times in that game but they
decided to call that play off sides now
I should have done a better job and say
well why do you think they called it in
that moment and they didn't call it the
other times but it's almost like the the
Chiefs are are acting like victims here
and I why do you think the NFL singled
out that play and didn't single out the
other ones that Tony was off sides on I
don't know why Dan and look I don't
believe there's some Grand conspiracy
that games are fixed that games are
rigged because frankly I don't think the
NFL is competent enough to pull that off
but I do know this in the age of
legalized gambling exactly what Roger
Goodell feared because there are quotes
and we'll use them from time to time
from 10 15 years ago where Goodell says
if you legalize gambling normal
incidents of the game will be viewed
with skepticism of Point shaving and
game fixing and we don't want legalized
gam because we don't want that that on
us so you could have someone out there
with the tin foil hat and it doesn't
require a whole lot of tin foil who
looks at that and Nick's right because
Dan orlovski had the video earlier this
week showing all the times that the
caderas Tony was offside why do you not
call it every time why do you wait until
the moment where the game is kind of on
the line two-minute Drive why does that
draw a flag is someone lying in wait for
the opportunity to derail the effort to
win the game I don't know and I don't
believe that to be the case but when you
have that kind of inconsistency that's
the problem Dan inconsistency and I've
been arguing they need to tear down the
officiating function and embrace
technology one of the points I made
yesterday they've had a laser beam first
down line for 10 years that they've been
trying to get the NFL's attention on you
put a laser beam out there that shows
the first down put a beam out there that
shows the line of scrimmage why does it
have to be a guessing game why is it a
mystery as to whether or not a guy's
lined up right put the line on the field
if you can we're not watching football
to make sure that all the players line
up properly before the play starts we
want to see what happens after the play
starts give him a chance to line up
properly if there's a technological way
to do it that would solve all this
because then he would have been flagged
the first time he did it and it would
have been a non-issue by the time the
end of the game came around what are the
Raiders going to do at head
coach well I think to answer that
question we need to go back to what they
didn't do two years ago when Rich baceo
was the interim coach after John guden
left took them to the playoffs almost
beat the Bengals who went on to the
Super Bowl that year and it was as if
Mark Davis gave no thought whatsoever to
keeping Rich Basia so this time around
not that they're a playoff team but when
you look at what Antonio Pierce is doing
the fire he brings to the job the
intense he's like the perfect Raiders
coach and to set the franchise record in
points scored four days after getting
shut out they're not quitting they're
not giving up they're not folding the
tents he's found way see this is why
we're talking about Brandon Staley being
fired and Antonio Pierce being hired
Lost season it's over it's done you're
playing out the string and you're
risking injury along the way Antonio
Pierce found a way to push the buttons
on his guys to get them to show up and
play their asses off and Brandon Staley
didn't and I think that that is coupled
with the fact that Mark Davis got it
wrong two years ago in not keeping Rich
Basia that might make him think now you
know what I'm not going to do this twice
I'll do a short-term contract but I want
to give this guy a chance from the
beginning the offseason all the way
through to the end of the season to see
what he can do if John Gruden wins his
lawsuit against the
NFL is there a chance he could coach the
Raiders again well I mean in theory
there's a chance he could coach any team
again any team could hire him anytime
they want but the Raiders are paying him
aren't they well they they worked out a
settlement okay of his remaining
contract back when he walked away and
that lawsuit Dan it is moving slowly
it's been two plus years January 11
there's going be a hearing before the
Nevada supreme court on the simple
question of whether or not the league
can pull the case into arbitration they
always want to bring the case into
arbitration because they control it it's
all secret and they're more likely to
win they never want anything to be in
open court they don't want their dirty
laundry to be aired out we still haven't
even resolved that question though we
are over two years into the case and we
won't have an answer until maybe may as
to whether or not it goes forward in
court or before the court of Roger
Goodell so it's going to be a while
until this is resolved and I think the
ship has sailed on John guden coaching
in the NFL but if there was anybody that
was going to hire him it's going to be
Mark Davis yeah and I wouldn't rule out
Mark Davis sticking his finger in the
eye of the league and taking the pr hit
you know it's been over two years
because the whole reason it was all PR
driven he didn't he didn't do anything
now it was emails he sent that were
horribly improper from 2011 time frame
that came to light and something had to
happen two years later what kind of
ground swell against it will there be if
Mark Davis decides to float that out
there so I I wouldn't rule it out
because there's nothing prohibiting him
from doing it if he's willing to be the
Pariah in the eyes of the NFL but he
kind of already is so what harm is done
by bringing guden back I don't think it
would happen but you can't take it off
the table all right I'll leave you with
this the team that's in the worst shape
right now is who oh it's Carolina
Panthers without question without
question because their owner is too
involved and he's not willing to step
aside and let the people who have
devoted their careers just like he
devoted his career to making a crapload
of money they've devoted their careers
to perfecting the art of of developing
and coaching football teams he wants to
be involved in everything he made that
clear a few weeks ago he reserves the
right to re to veto any decision made
even if he's going against every single
person in his football operation he
reserves the right to say this is what I
want and until he steps back this team
is going to be a mess thanks for joining
us Mike good luck with the book thanks
for joining us as always thanks Dan good
talking to you Budd have a great week
that's Mike Florio pro football talk
live co-host show that precedes ours on
peacock